hi guys silver a2 and today i've got
another time-lapse for you and other
time-lapse of the main street buildings
but the good news is this is actually
going to be the last time lapse of these
main street buildings after this I'm
going to be working on the entrance area
mainly getting a nice square that you
know you can just walk around in and I
might add some entrance ticket booth
stuff like that but I might get to that
later because honestly I'm not too good
at that yet so that's going to be the
next episode and after that I'll
probably work on the square in the
middle of the park from which I'll
actually walk into the different areas
of the park now about this episode right
here is really just a bit finishing up
the Main Street getting the buildings
that I currently have the unfinished
kind of finished and just adding one
more building I think that's pretty much
it's also adding up some back sides to
these buildings and just changing some
details in general adding some small
planters and stuff just basically kind
of finishing this stuff up and these oh
wait I was actually going to add two
buildings to the square I lied I'm sorry
I was going to add two buildings to the
square but it's not really too
interesting over here it's just a simple
filler building I wasn't really sure on
the stream because in one hand this is a
pillar building but I really didn't want
to say that I didn't want to put too
much effort into these buildings just
because there are filler buildings and
they're on the sides because every
building decide you know every building
kind of deserve some love and I don't
want to have some unfinished buildings
hanging around just because they're on
the side and they're supposed to fill up
the space so I guess what what I'm
trying to get at here is that you always
want to have these buildings these
signature buildings here and there that
actually you know get all the attention
like the corner buildings are really
important you always want to get them
right and if you do have the bellas like
I kind of have over here just place in
the middle square and make sure it gets
all the attention by having some kind of
bell tower or more details than other
buildings or maybe even a difference in
colors but if you do have some side
buildings like I have over here you
should probably still put a lot of
different a lot of detail in it's
because you know otherwise it's just too
different from the rest of the buildings
and it kind of breaks the immersion
experience at least that's what I think
so these buildings are just kind of here
to be filler buildings but not only
sense that they are just very simple and
ugly and I don't give a [ __ ] about them
they're just there because I really
needed to
fill up this space over here so I would
actually have a coherent square that you
know wouldn't break by because of um I
don't know foliage or something like
that I didn't want to surround the
square with foliage I just wanted to
have buildings all around the thing and
that's basically what I'm working on
this these things also it was a good
other opportunity to get a more Alpine
styled building out here because even
though the main street isn't really a
mix of themes as much as I'm going to
have to have a mix of themes in the rest
of the park because you know I'll have
these Asian areas and European areas
mixed together but in the main street I
kind of didn't want to have that because
I have this feeling that that just won't
work out now and there was just too much
difference in the themes I don't think
it would really work out to have you
know European buildings like this and
then put a agent temple next to it but I
still want to have a lot of various
different European influences throughout
the thing and this is definitely one of
the more Alpine buildings but as you can
see still some Main Street influences
with the windows and stuff like that so
I guess it still kind of forms a
coherent kind of facade I'm not sure on
that one but yeah if anything goes wrong
with these buildings I'll just say yeah
that's because it's a filler building
and if it goes tell them if it goes all
the way right and it looks like a
beautiful building then I'll just say
that that was all on purpose of course
then that's how that works that's my
genius in any case this is really the
only building action that you're going
to see today and at this point I think
all the buildings in the main street are
pretty much finished except for a couple
of details so on ya know it's time to
work on some foliage small things
placing benches little bins stuff like
that it's definitely something I don't
want to miss out on even after this
episode I didn't really add too many
details in the sense of flags and stuff
like that and there's something I still
want to think about maybe I don't even
add some trolley wires but I'll add its
Rolly if I can find a way to get that to
work I think there's a revolutionary
right one I'll pick something up but I
don't know about the trolley wires
because the only experience I have with
that is that it just kind of ruins every
single streets like in every single city
in the world where you have the most
beautiful city with amazing buildings
then there's trolley wires everywhere
and you can't see [ __ ] that's not what I
want to my Main Street so I'm probably
going for that trolley
Disneyland but not have the wires over
it because out of scenery reasons and I
think that should work fine not to worry
about that honestly this building over
you know this building okay there's
something I kind of wanted to talk about
it's this effect that as soon as you
work on the theme for very long and
you've started making a number of
buildings for it they just start looking
similar because what I want to do at
least is to some extent is - even if I'm
within one theme have very very
different variations of course some
sceneries that are used and the pieces
that I use so that at least there's a
bit of difference and you know every
building doesn't look exactly the same
but as long as you use a similar kind of
theme for many buildings you just end up
using the same kind of sets and I guess
that's the problem that I'm right now
approaching with a Main Street and I
guess that's a reason why it's good that
this Main Street it's just this more I'm
not slightly larger because at this
point I find myself reusing pieces that
I've used before in buildings and in the
same kind of way like this building even
though it doesn't have the same build-up
it still has the same pieces for example
as the building on the other side next
to the blue building which has those I
don't know if you can call them
Victorian but it still has those wooden
influences and you know it kind of looks
similar even though it has a different
roof structure there's things that I
start to pick up similarities between
buildings and I think right at that
point is the best point to stop using a
one theme and just move on to another
theme or just start experimenting with
different sets because otherwise things
start looking too similar and at least
in my opinion that's something I kind of
want to avoid it's also one of the
emerging breaking experiences
experiences but in a different way it
kind of makes you realise that this is a
roller coaster cone 3 and not an actual
like a theme park we're talking about
because you start recognizing so many
custom scenery sets and for me
recognizing custom scenery sets is not a
bad thing per se but recognizing in a
way that most people use them like
recognizing shyguys alpine village in
combination with catfish Cove which is a
very very common thing and I understand
that because it's very easy to use but
it's something that I've seen so many
times before that it just looks like oh
now that's another roller coaster can 3d
project yeah that's not hard to notice
well well you know using custom scenery
sets that many people don't use together
kind of creates a fresh kind of new look
and I guess that's also why everybody's
always looking forward to see new custom
scene reset so much because it means
that you can mess around with new things
and for at least the small while it kind
of doesn't look as much as the things
you've seen so many times before and I
guess that is one of the advantages of
doing something like that and that's
basically what I want to avoid in this
bike so if I really have to I'll mix a
lot of sets even if that doesn't work as
much for time lapses because like you
may know it does take a long time to
actually experiment with sets especially
especially if you're not very
experienced with it with the Main Street
it's a bit of a different thing because
I mean I have used the Main Street quite
a lot I know many people who have used
the Main Street set quite a lot and even
though there are nine different sets
almost everybody who uses them knows
where all the pieces are and stuff like
that so in that sense that those sets
are really easy to mix and it doesn't
really take time to experiment with it
but if you're going to new theme and
you're trying out new sets and mixing
things and seeing how it works it always
takes a while to understand which sets
have which pieces and how you can use
them together so I'm not sure whether
that's going to work out too well in the
time-lapse but I still want to give it a
shot and like I said I think I already
apologized for my possibly not as great
time lapses as before because I really
want to focus on how good the park is
going to be and just kind of leave the
time lapses right there just just record
while I'm playing and use the time
lapses to release of my YouTube channel
but otherwise pretty much disregard that
so yeah I do apologize if my time lapses
do start to become a bit you know a bit
not so great and do involve a lot of
building things in there removing things
but I hope you can understand that I
kind of want to do go for some
experimentation in the park here and
there especially with the themes that I
don't know yet even if I start
practising them before so I actually
kind of know what things I can do with
it it still does take a while to get
your buildings right sometimes in any
case this is just the backs the back
signs of the buildings once again I
really wanted to get this everywhere and
I might actually go into quite some
quote-unquote full detail on the
backsides in terms of small roads and
lampposts and
areas for the I don't know the personnel
to actually be and kill I don't know
what they do over there but just just
for the stars to be somewhere and I
don't know if it's really a good idea
but it's just something that I felt like
doing because even if I don't show this
in the final video I realize that you
know I'm making time lapses of this
anyway and as a whole it does make the
park look a lot better and it kind of
allows me to make aerial shots of the
park as well and it's just more fun to
look at the park when you can actually
see those backstage areas too it just
makes it look a tiny bit more real even
if even if these buildings don't look as
great yes because you know it it's time
to add some air vents and small cornices
to those things so that's what I'm doing
now I still feel like I really want to
have these things around it's it's just
at first I figured it's do something for
me I wanted to have this bike look just
a tiny bit more realistic when I was
looking at it while I was building so
that's why I did this I really don't
know if it's the best idea but many
people actually do this and it's quite
handy in general to with your park
layout it's because you do have to kind
of plan the park more a.m. in terms of
the sign buildings especially when it
comes to dark rides because you always
need to place them on the sides because
they are such enormous big boxes behind
them were in which you place the dark
rides you do have to keep in mind with
the park layout that you have these
backstage areas and I think that even if
you do this subconsciously it just makes
the park layout in general a lot more
realistic because real points have to
think about this - real parks have to
think about where they can get their
backstage areas and how they deal with
that so in a way I think it it really
might actually make the park layout as a
whole a lot more realistic in any case
I'm almost starting to work on the
square over there and then I'm like nah
let's not do that let's just work in the
entrance square and I guess that's a
cool idea because I can't want to I kind
of wanted to get that done first at this
point I still don't really know what I'm
going to do with the parking lots I know
that I'm going to build it I just don't
know where I'm going to build it and how
exactly and where I'm going to have the
ticket booths and stuff like that but
honestly I have a feeling and I think
that many people have the same kind of
feeling it's that
okay silver at you were you've worked it
along enough for about like on all these
buildings and it's really time to get to
some rides and what the coast is because
we want to see that and honestly I kind
of you like that as well so yeah I'll
just leave that parking lot area for now
besides I've never found it too much fun
to build parking lots I do want to go
into it at some point for the realism of
it but really attractions at this point
are my number one priority so I should
really get into that soon a couple of
episodes still stay strong so this
little thing over here is just that I
decided to add a little porch over here
and I guess that's a little thing I can
throw out there if you ever have a
building where you're not so sure
whether it actually looks good just
throw a porch on there if you really can
because you can have like hanging
flowers and cool wooden stuff and in it
it always looks good I think it's always
a nice little thing to add and it's not
too hard I definitely recommend using
station gyms of Western set to I think
that is or it might be one either one of
those and using the trellises from
Station Jim's gunning it it's actually
really great and those hanging flowers
by the way are from n7s hanging baskets
they're really awesome so if you have a
chance to pick them up they are just
amazing so you you should do that if you
want them in any case this is just a
tiny bit of gardening because I felt
like the main street wasn't green enough
and if you have some buildings that
you're not a fan of like you know just
answer used to them in any case this is
it for this episode so thank you for
watching and I'll see you all next time